what up anime fans it's goes on and kid
card we're here to talk about episodes I
have no idea I got it all like 50 and 51
or something or a 52 and 53 we'll figure
it out we'll figure it anyways I think
it said to 152 not important anyways so
we got I gotta say this has been some
crazy episodes like oh my god yeah you
can say oh my god again can't you what
do you mean I know you just like my as a
character yeah so okay guys point to
something relevant here my are you guys
if you guys been following our weekly
episodes and our bi-weekly episodes
you'd realize that my like was my
favorite character and when she died I
hate it cuz like I love the romantic
plot between like trunks and future my
and I just hated it that my eye was dead
and i like my even more than trunks
really and so when we thought my was
dead which I mean like I don't know it
was pretty clear at one point that she
was dead and maybe some people would be
like hey man I like that they brought
her back it's kind of cheesy but then
again it is driven by don't care I love
it that she's back that's what I'm happy
about I'm happy to see future my I like
the backstory that the newest episode
gave about her and I thought it was
excellent the fact that she was back me
when she woke up at the end of the
second last episode I I went like crazy
I was so happy and even even the goku's
fighting it was so interesting and even
all this talk of time travel in the
theory of time travel we're really
getting some solid sci-fi like theory
here and the dragon ball super universe
i gotta say i think these last two
episodes
were written better than any of the
previous episodes except maybe excluding
some of the movies yeah yeah I like that
I don't know if I like them maybe as
much as I did when my Goku is fighting
hit in the tournament that was pretty
epic but like yeah they're good I like
it um one thing I want to talk about is
I think Bly goku's might be slightly
exaggerated how powerful he is what do
you think I'm gonna just feel one
comment before I didn't get to it so I
disagree with kid Kai I don't think the
head part was better but maybe that's
because ke kai is just more like an
action guy I'm more of a like I I like
care about relationships I care about
like character dynamics and I just feel
like right now we're getting much deeper
relationship dynamics and like exploring
humanity more that we our just fighting
like leaving magida when he comforted
trunks at the end of the second last
episode that was beautiful like you when
do you see what Gina be that touching it
was like a little moment it was like him
just just barely saying something to
trunk but it was enough and it was
comforting and you gotta love it you
gotta love it and what you were saying
with the black oh cool being like
overpowered or being thinking that his
or power that's definitely true and I
mean we expected we said it we set it in
the last episode review that it's
probably going to be a situation where
he comes then they separate and then
they have to train and my vitamin get
here it seems like they don't have to
train it seems like black oak glass the
train which is weird and for the first
time we see a situation where black Goku
is actually he you just want to kill the
guys he'd rather leave them in the past
and take over the future which is
interesting because usually we have the
bad guys were chasing the good guys here
we have the good guys were chasing the
bad guys and again we're continuing with
that idea that the good guys are
stronger than the bad guys yeah this
interesting we're gonna see what happens
I wonder who this guy actually is
what his original form is and how he's
going to look like like this well you
know how know that this he is somehow
using goku's body future goku's body and
he is inside and I don't know if you did
something similar to captain ginyu where
he has some kind of body position blah
blah blah technique thing but it's
fascinating to think about and I'm
finally excited that we're going to get
more development into that of like who
finally the green KY is next episode if
you guys sell oh man and and the episode
is called like like what is like love
that transcends time or something yeah
that's the first title how sick is that
because now we're gonna get more by of
trunks which I love and now we're going
to also see who the green KY is which
man that is a big mystery up till now
and even though let's talk about black
goku's like motivations of it cuz like
it's funny because I mean you can easily
discard him as like being like another
villain you know crazy wants to destroy
the world wants to bring like misery
upon humanity but he says his goals like
exterminate humanity because he's been
watching them studying humans and has
decided that it's better for the world
he can create a utopia a better world by
destroying the humans and that's like a
motif we've seen in a lot of even
literature and then like anime as well
and what is your take on that on his
view because he's not doing it as he's
hurting people he's doing it as he's
helping the world and to be fair humans
have done some pretty atrocious things
even in real life that dragon ball super
is pretty much drawing upon yeah
definitely makes you question who the
villain is like he it's kind of hard to
compare to anything in real life because
we don't have any aliens coming to Earth
threatening to the stress because
required of cancerous to their own
planet but like um it's interesting
because your slate your sucky doesn't
have any
motivation like the way freeze that the
other way sell that the way majin buu
did you know it's even different than B
raspberries was definitely also
different type of element like the three
main ones from dragon ball z but like
it's interesting i like the aspect of
like it's going to develop more um are
we good are we bad it's going to make us
question ourselves you know what i mean
like is he actually doing something
that's right or maybe is he may be a bit
crazy to go along with their you know
what i mean like that phone like you
know he he he he sees definitely things
from a different view because he he's
somehow connected to kies in god and he
has a much deeper and profound
understanding of how the universe works
but then again you can also ask the
question like who is he really to judge
humans you know he's knocked the god of
destruction he's not a chi of creation
that we know of so far but i'm sure he'd
be a lot more powerful if he was a god
of destruction it's like yeah it's like
death notice he's the light yagami of
this show right now and I mean you know
a lot of people really for light yagami
so we have an interesting situation and
at least it's not black and white
anymore because most super you're all
like I've been super villain in in
Dragon Ball super ah enjoying ballsy
kind of motivational stupidos it to be
the strong as sort of wipe out humanity
for no reason or on to increase their
empire like Frieza or just boot was like
you don't know why he doesn't know boo
boo's just a brainless more gas line for
destruction angry but this is like real
it's like motivation like we don't get
that a lot and that's what I'm saying
like this arc is bringing in higher
writing like it's bringing better
writing and it's not just relying on the
fighting which I like yeah yeah I agree
like their motivation was always one
dimension
Dragon Ball Z in terms of maybe not so
much Frieza because he was like some
kind of like a galactic LEM like pirate
pirate / thing but even he was kind of
like one-dimensional you know just
conquer everything kind of flex my might
across the universe or galaxy and
definitely you know cell was just like
you know he may have been from arguably
the best saga and the whole thing but he
was just the because like because he was
made for many peoples our cells and
stuff like that he does really have a
striking resemblance to freeze they even
though I can't remember exactly he was
just vein right if you want to cheat his
perfect form you wanted to be like his
perfect self so that was his motivation
right yeah I was perfection and pure
strength and then again obviously
probably trying to actually go home
flexing his muscles across the universe
blah blah blah he has succeeded and yeah
beating him on earth but yeah at the end
of the day we haven't had someone who
appears to have at at at least their end
seems to be positive in their opinion
right we don't agree with his like means
but his ends is creating a better world
because we've had like tyrants in real
life was thought they were creating a
better world yeah yeah killer was
arguably all day I think he thought in
his mind he thought he was creating a
better world and reality wasn't yeah but
it's a comparison nonetheless yeah so
anyway is amazing stuff happening right
now dragon ball super I gotta admit this
is like rewarding didn't think this
would be the case like I was starting to
think that the art wouldn't pan out into
something great but right now with these
last two episodes I definitely think
we're back on track any concluding
thoughts yeah I just want to talk about
it's going to be interesting when trunks
meets go home for the first one because
trunks probably hasn't seen Gohan and
like I don't know 16 17 years but he saw
him like.he he saw him you know when he
was a teen but like you know now he's
seeing
overall so virginal go on because like
the Gohan's in his future go on was
older and you know this is his teacher
his mentor his best friend you know this
is some she's arguably his deepest
relationship that he said anybody you
know for him it was extraordinarily
emotional will go hon was killed by 17
and 18 and you know that triggered his
original Super Saiyan transformation you
know it kind of kicked things off for
the cell saga back and Dragon Ball Z you
know in the dynamics now he's gonna see
that Gohan's the greats a man a big turd
you know what I mean this knocked her
that I like no no I feel like all
positive stuff here I feel like this is
great I feel like Gohan's coming back
into this he's coming back at their mix
is exactly what we asked for before the
earth see more of going on and it seems
like we saw in turn Super Saiyan it
seems like he's gonna be training and
I'm very excited I know there's gonna be
some comedy with the great soon and
they're showing him that's got to be
formula I'll say yeah like maybe he's
going to be a bit surprised that like is
this really my go on you know cuz no one
ever became the great well grace a man
again that would be them were responding
to fans and like they've been doing that
a lot in my the fan theories and to just
fan opinion in general they've been like
kind of like self reflexively joking
about it so that maybe one of these
moments definitely for sure alright guys
that's it for this week's reviews and
this has been goals and kick guy and
we'll see you later space cowboys